parlons donc de cette initiative de la
nouvelle présidente de la commission
européenne elle s'appelle ours ou la
faune der leyen on va bientôt connaître
parfaitement son nom et en annonçant les
nouveaux membres de la commission eh
bien elle nous a annoncé qu' il y avait
un commissaire chargé je cite la
protection du mode de vie européen
qu'est ce que ça veut dire eh bien
écoutez la principale intéressée
présidente marguerite et srinath des
beauty vous avez expliqué que la
nouvelle présidente de la commission
européenne était formidable parce
qu'elle était parfaitement francophone
de toute évidence n'est pas là seulement
qu'elle pratique mais je referme la
parenthèse alors protection du mode de
vie européen
certains y voient déjà une sorte de
charge contre l'immigration ou une
volonté un peu identitaire écoutez la
réaction d'amélie de montchalin c'est la
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes ll est un peu gêné aux
entournures quand même il ya
effectivement des intitulés de postes
qu'il faut qu'on comprenne mieux parce
que j'avais entendu d'un discours dur
sur la fin d'al rayan que j'avais trouvé
très intéressant l'époque d'ajouter ton
de la commission près nous avions tous
sur tous les bancs polisy trouvé ça
intéressant c'est qu'elle avait dit
quévert yuping way un chemin européen
elle avait cité les droits sociaux elle
avait cité la protection voilà le droit
d'asile comme une partie notre identité
elle avait cité le fait qu'on donne
accès à l'éducation à tous elle avait
cité au fond ce qui fait notre identité
mais qu'ils étaient des choses positives
le ciss fides que ce nouveau poste de
commissaire c'est fait pour rassurer les
pays d'europe de l'est par exemple la
hongrie ou la pologne que je pense en
tout cas c'est l'intitulé est
incompréhensible
est ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
ne prend pas par exemple termes de
migration alors qu'on sait bien que
c'est un des points centraux sur
lesquels sur le projet européen il ya
une discussion comme vous le dites entre
les pays de l'est mais aussi la grèce
d'où est originaire le commissaire
en prononçant pas ce terme de migration
le malaise est à son comble parce que du
coup elle suscite les attaques
elle donne le sentiment qu'elle dit deux
choses contradictoires c'est lorsqu'elle
défend cette expression que personne ne
comprend elle dit à la fois il faut
s'accrocher à nos valeurs donc est ce
que l'idée c'est de se défendre contre
le monde extérieur les valeurs
européennes sont elles ne sont elles ou
européennes ou universelle elle pose
cette question et en même temps elle dit
il faut respecter la dignité de chacun
donc elle dit deux choses qui
apparaissent mal articulés voire
contradictoires donc c'est évidemment
une maladresse ou moins sémantique et à
partir de là moi je dis franchement que
le mieux c'est d'assumer le terme
migration on peut pas supprimer le terme
migration du portefeuille d'un
commissaire sinon ça donne le sentiment
que on entérine le désaccord qui existe
déjà de fait entre différents pays
membres de l'union européenne
la charte c'est une fausse bonne idée je
pense que la formulation est absolument
qu'est la mi temps calamiteuse
parce qu'en plus ça envoie une
rhétorique d'extrême droite
la france enfin là l'europe catholique
blanche
en plus c'est une forme de luxe d'être
forcément l'extrême droite vous êtes
encore absolument mais s'est employé par
l'extrême mode de cet été alors en plus
c'est une formule qui a été utilisé par
viktor orban lors de la campagne
européenne et qui a lui-même dit qu'il
avait sauvé le mode de vie européen en
bouclant ses frontières donc on est
complètement dans cette thématique l'
immigration
bon je trouve que ça va à l'encontre de
l'esprit européen qui celui justement de
l'union elle parle de valeur mais
vraiment ça opère une espèce de
confrontation totale avec ce qu on peut
penser de l'europe donc union une sorte
de d'humanisme politique et en plus on
ne se reconnaît absolument pas
là dedans il ya une grande partie des
gens qui ont voté aux élections
européennes une majorité du flan on va
dire gauche libéraux centristes qui sont
majoritaires au parlement aujourd'hui
qui ne se reconnaissent absolument pas
dans cette formulation de qui qui
évoquent le repli une forme implicite de
rejet enfin donc c'est à mon sens donner
complètement des gages aux populistes
c'est vraiment aller dans le sens de la
pression populiste extrêmement
malheureux je crois qu'elle devrait très
vite changer sa formulation jérôme
sainte-marie la protection du mode de
vie européen c'était une position
extrémiste a pas du tout non mais je
trouve ça extrêmement intéressant par
ailleurs parce que ça met l'europe face
à ses contradictions
puisque justement à l'ordinaire il ya
une première contradiction dans ce conte
dans ce qu'on a entendu c'est que le
mode de vie les valeurs c'est deux
choses différentes
déjà donc ça c'est un petit peu assez un
petit problème premier pouvoir l'autre
chose c'est que quand on commence à
réfléchir à ce qu'il ya de commun dans
l'europe
c'est une question que s'est posée par
exemple au moment de la libye les débats
sur les frontières et sur
l'élargissement et on tombe assez
rapidement quand même sur les notions de
chrétienté par exemple et plus
précisément et en dehors du monde
orthodoxe et l'islam de l'autre côté il
n'y a pas ce qu'il n'y a pas tellement
de points communs parce qu'il n'ya pas
de peuple européen
et c'est là où ça devient un peu
compliqué son affaire c'est que si on
fait un mode de vie européen s'est pas
seulement
c'est à dire qu'on crée une unité non
seulement par rapport à l'extérieur ce
qui est déjà pas facile mais surtout à
créer une unité à l'intérieur or il ya
des cultures européennes
dans cet ensemble marquée par la
chrétienté par le réseau des techniques
et des universités au moyen-âge et c'est
qu'on essaye de trouver
qu'est ce que c'est que l'europe à part
un petit bout de continent on n'a pas
grand chose et est donc à ce moment là
on est confronté à cette idée mais si on
parle des modes de vie les modes de vie
ils ont une existence un peu régionales
ça dépend des endroits est en tout cas
en largement nationale et donc on peut
considérer que les différences assez
importante et c'est là où du coup il ya
une contradiction avec une pareille voit
pas la contradiction exactement vous
voulez vous l'avez vous la mettez mais
c'est que on en ramène un truc un
échelon européen où malheureusement ou
heureusement je ne sais pas on va butter
sur les aspects civilisationnel assez
clair c'est une peña qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
c'est pour moi
pour le coup je me situe dans la
prolongation de ce que vient de dire
jérôme c'est qu'en l'occurrence on a
quand même un vrai problème aujourd'hui
qui est que les gens se sentent attaqués
en termes de civilisation sans définir
exactement ceux qui seraient attaqués
comment ça le serez et qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas réservé par qui est donc on
est exactement la dent autrement dit on
envoie des messages qui se veulent
rassurants mais qui à force d'être dans
le flou et de ne désigner personne et de
ne jamais être explicite laisse
finalement monté tous les fantasmes il
est clair que je pense pas que cette
commission européenne sont en train de
dériver vers l'extrême droite c'est pas
le cas mais en l'occurrence elle va
ranimer des débats qui sont des débats
fort peu intéressants tout simplement
parce qu'effectivement il n'ya pas de
peuple européen
il n'y a pas de constitution réellement
européennes et qu'aujourd'hui le vrai
problème est un problème personne ce
sens citoyen européen ou considère un
autre européen comme son concitoyen donc
et en même temps l'europe avance de plus
en plus en faisant des lois qui sont des
lois morales qui sont des lois qui
interviennent dans le mode
d'administration des pays à un moment
donné il va falloir avoir faire un choix
clair soit on est dans une union
économique
et puis après tout pourquoi pas on a des
alliances ou on est dans une union
politique et là on a un vrai problème
qui est qu'on n'a pas d'identité qu'on
n'est pas tous d'accord sur ce que
signifie être européen avec à mon avis
met l'accent sur des choses qui ne crée
pas d'unité et sur lesquels les gens
n'adhèrent pas en masse et effectivement
c'est se mettre dans la difficulté sans
avoir les moyens d'en sortir
donc je pense qu'elle n'aura pas d'autre
choix que de repartir sur des intitulés
beaucoup plus basique de type migration
ça dépend de quel message il veut le
faire passer
mais à mon avis il faut sortir de cette
fausse annonce il n'y a pas de
aujourd'hui de valeurs que porte la
commission européenne auquel les peuples
adhèrent de façon explicite
enfin les yeux réagir le 6 me dis que
j'ai un vus sursauté quand vous avez dit
qu avait pas de citoyenneté européenne
je vous donne d'abord la vie de nos
chers internautes celui de broc qui nous
dit honnêtement je ne sais pas ce qu'est
le mode de vie européen
peter et nous explique lucile schmid va
adorer j'aurais préféré protection des
ethnies européenne car il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'un mode de vie
et puis bonito qui nous dit j'avoue à la
limite comprendre la notion de valeurs
occidentales mais mode de vie européen
j'ai plus de mal et puis voici l'avis
des internautes du figaro puisque c'est
la question du jour sur le figaro.fr
êtes vous choqué par l'intitulé de ce
nouveau poste de commissaire et bien non
figurez vous sur 48 mille et quelques
autant 79% ne sont pas choqués je tiens
ma promesse et je passe la parole à du
silence que je voulais dire c'est que
ursula von der leyen a une réputation en
allemagne d'être quelqu'un assez droit
dans ses bottes si je puis dire mais
assez maladroit il ya aussi un problème
de passage de témoin entre la position
d'angela merkel qui quand même c'est
faire remarquer a acquis beaucoup de
légitimité comme comme dirigeante
européenne par sa position sur la
migration et d'écouté celle qu'on
présente comme l'héritière d'angela
merkel au fond esquivé la question
migratoire donc je pense qu'il ya déjà
un problème très important qui sera
certainement un il y aura des règlements
de comptes à ok corral
à mon avis en allemagne sur ce sujet la
deuxième chose par rapport à la
citoyenneté européenne pour réagir par
rapport à ce que vous disiez c'est que
je pense que c'est pas une sujet
juridique c'est plus une question
culturelle et je pense qu'on en tout cas
en termes générationnel je suis persuadé
qu'il ya un sentiment de citoyenneté
européenne qui est partagée aujourd'hui
par cette génération des 25 40 ans après
le contenu à lui donner en termes de
droit c'est un sujet sur lequel il ya
une discussion à voir qu'ils soient une
discussion à la fois sociétal et
politique mais je pense que le sentiment
d'être européen est très partagé y
compris d'ailleurs lire ma génération a
la cinquantaine et puis juste un tout
petit pour pas monopoliser la parole ce
que je pense c'est que à ne pas avoir le
débat sur la migration d'emblée elle
court le risque déjà elle a été quand
même mal à prouver cela van der leyen ça
a été très compliqué de trouver une
présidente elle court le risque de
donner le sentiment qu'elle est dans l'
esquive et ce qui va se passer c'est que
ça commencera très mal alors il faut
rajouter je pense que
enfin quand j'entends les gens se
sentent attaqués dans leur civilisation
bas je pense pas que tous les gens moi
personnellement je me sens pas attaquer
dans ma civilisation je pense que c'est
globalisation ces formules globalisante
il faut faire attention
il y a des gens qui se sentent attaqués
dans leur identité nationale ça je veux
bien l'entendre mais tout le monde ne
l'est pas de la même façon je pense
qu'on peut se retrouver sur des valeurs
européennes occidentales qui s'enracine
dans une certaine culture la culture des
lumières ce sont des valeurs assez
général je parlais d'humanisme tout à
l'heure et bien oui et d'ailleurs la
laïcité elle s'enracine dans ces valeurs
là donc chrétienne et chrétienne aussi
je dis pas failli et produira hills
hotel a décidé de fermer leur espace
ça permet le respect des croyances donc
du coup abbassi la laïcité
je sais qu'on a plusieurs lectures de la
laïcité en fait le problème c'est que
hilliard et la laïcité la face à ces
déjà permettre permettre à chacun de
croire ce qu'il veut mais ce n'est pas à
l'état de décider d'imposer ou de
favoriser telle religion plutôt qu'une
autre donc pour moi neutralité de livres
oui mais pour moi c'est toute façon la
laïcité n'est pas que la neutralité
enfin le dernier mot je pense qu'il ya
des valeurs tout à fait commune en
europe enfin l'ailier me semble dans la
culture européenne lainiers me semble
assez assez étrange et dernier point je
pense que cette formulation est vite en
fait un débat qui est à mon sens
extrêmement important c'est celui de
l'intégration
on parle sans arrêt de l'immigration
donc on parle des immigrés illégaux
mais l'enjeu aussi il est celui
d'intégrer là je boucle sur le mode de
vie c'est parce que la question se pose
en effet qu'est ce qu'on fait pour que
ces gens là qui sont étrangers en effet
adhère s'intègre à notre culture c'est
ça la vraie crise à la réalisation elle
est là juste en bois j'aimerais passer
migration je te pour l'instant de toute
façon dans les intitulés qu'on a vu
l'immigration c'est nous qu'il
interprète on peut penser ça mais en
fait elle met ses patrons prenons au
sérieux si vous voulez la l'intitulé ça
renvoie à cette idée que effectivement
il y aurait à une communauté de valeurs
pourquoi pas enfin que moins de valeur
on l'a
au niveau international on est nous y
sommes tous très fort cette planète et
donc tant qu'on y est pourquoi pas mais
c'est surtout le fait est ce que il ya
ce sentiment d'être européen
est ce parce que disait tout à l'heure
qui va croissant si au fond faut pas
voir une conception des techniques de
ces choses là si si les gens se disent
est ce que je me sens européen sic on
fait des enquêtes de valeur c'est pareil
bon ben c'est pareil ça s'est transformé
pourquoi pas où ça tu vois tes copines
on ne savait pas très bien sauf que
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on observe et la
de ce point de vue là les sondages qui
souvent ne servent à rien à part feront
quand même leur utilité spam
l'objectiver des choses il ya beaucoup
d' enquêtes qui sont faites pour sûr au
niveau européen elles sont faites très
généralement je pense notamment une
enquête de france jean jaurès pour
trouver que bien sûr il ya un peu plus
grand emprunt que bien sûr l'europe
c'est formidable c'est donc la vision
idéologique des commanditaires
généralement est très favorable à
l'europe et des commentateurs aussi
et qu'est ce qu'on voit on va d'une part
que plus on est jeune aujourd'hui et moi
on se sent européen mais quand j'étais
savez pas quels jeunes les plus
qualifiés 73 entre amis c'est maintenant
c'est un signe extérieur de richesse que
nous sortirons formidable et
d'intelligence évidemment les choses
autour de l'accès aux études
ce fut quand ils voulaient quand il
avait inscrit la région sud est une
reproduction quand j'étais à sciences po
nous d'appliquer des gens le suivent
toujours des ratios de peau je crois que
évidemment l'avenir c'est de sentir
européen qu'on avait de plus en plus
sentir honoré c'est le contraire
aujourd'hui c'est les retraités qui se
sentent sont davantage attachée à
l'europe que que les jeunes et quand
vous êtes jeunes
alors évidemment si vous êtes dans une
grande école de commerce et grâce à vous
sentir européen vous sentez d'un grand
n'importe quoi ou sont américains
ça doit bien mais si vous prenez les
chiffres en tout cas des toutes les
enquêtes
allez voir nous non seulement le
sentiment d'être plus européen que
français ou d'être auto autant combien
de français a tendance à décroître au
niveau global mais des croix dans les
jeunes générations une dernière pour
l'intégrer selon les chiffres en
maintenant sur l'intégration
un ensemble qui ne définit pas ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui la citoyenneté
européenne un contenu extrêmement floues
c'est très difficile de s'intégrer à des
gens qui ne savent pas qu'ils sont et
qu'ils ne savent pas le dire est qu'ils
ne sont même pas d'accord entre eux
forcément sur ce qu'ils sont